the Kentucky high school whose students
are at the center of a video controversy
it's closed today due to safety concerns
local authorities are also now
investigating threats made against some
of the Covington Catholic High students
after videos shows an encounter with a
Native American man in Washington a
chaperone who was on the trip so
students were targeted for wearing mega
hats and describes what happened I think
that was one of the reasons they were
targeted and I think they were also
targeted for what they stood for which
is Christianity the right for life we
were standing there and we looked and
all of a sudden they turned their
attention to our group and they were
screaming horrible horrible things that
I will not repeat to our children to
children not adults they were screaming
them at children to Covington students
are describing some of the apparent
threats there have been many threats
against their lives against our parents
some of these threats include that we
should all be locked in the school and
it's been burned to the ground the
school being bombed school shooting
threats it's really scary and Nathan
Phillips the Native American activist
saying he is willing to meet with the
students so we'll see if that happens
Jessie I want to take a listen to an
exchange on the view today which kind of
kept encapsulated the whole argument
watch this isn't that we just instantly
say that's what it is based on what we
see in that moment and then have to walk
step back when it turns out we're wrong
why is that why is do we keep making the
same mistake because we're desperate to
get Trump out of office
I think that that's the reason I think
oppressed jumps the gun a lot because we
just we have so much circumstantial
evidence against this guy that we
basically how hoping that you know
Cohen's got the goods and what have you
been so it's wishful thinking
there you have it I've always said that
shows filled with a lot of wisdom you
might have a book one day and you might
get invited on the view she was just
saying what was on her mind and maybe
that is what happened it's true I think
the media tried to Cavanagh these
teenagers and it's really inspired the
rest of the country because you see this
injustice and they've turned these kids
into folk heroes at this point just
because of a face crime the guy made a
face and stood there and did what all
adults tell young people to do with this
moment not for a punch not yelled not do
anything he just stood there like this
and that was the crime and this is a
great lesson now whenever you see a
story in the media and everybody starts
to pile on step back think about the
Covington boys and just wait into the
facts come out some people are learning
their lessons and other people's aren't
I think some left-wing person went to a
high school basketball photo and the
guys were going like this and they said
that's a white power symbol no that
means someone just hit a three-pointer
everybody knows that watches basketball
so I learned from Parkland children are
off-limits I thought that's what was
supposed to be the lesson and now you
have a situation where the Hat was
offensive the smirk was offensive and
this is coming from the same people that
were yelling and chasing people and
their families out of restaurants so it
doesn't really equate right there and
you mentioned the Indian at the top he
was not a Vietnam veteran that came out
the New York Times had to clarify he
served during the Vietnam era mm-hmm it
was the Washington Post I think that did
that and maybe they're all okay so you
you've read all you read all these
papers that's how you know Gregg David
Brooks wrote a piece of day talking
about how we destroy lives today and
that when the further when the story
first broke on Twitter everyone was like
oh okay so they bust
racist and then the next day it's like
Oh liberals must all be bad because they
thought they were racist and then it was
just basically all of our biases coming
out one story who's David Brooks there
are people there are people who even
with the new information are clinging to
this like a life preserver for example
actor has been Jim Carrey this is his
latest painting in which obviously he is
demonizing these teenagers I have to
hand it to him that now his pictures are
as bad as his pictures anyway reality so
right now what you're having is reality
is crashing down it wasn't this was a
left-wing fantasy you had the perfect
villains right wit Magga hats white kids
you had the perfect victim Catholic at a
pro-life pointed perfect perfect Law &
Order
suspect right you know they just needed
to have super rich parents who are
architects and then you had the perfect
victim Native American Vietnam vet who
is isolated so what happens with the
story like that it's too good to check
and between this story and the BuzzFeed
story the media is in worse shape than
my liver after Spring Break I don't know
how you gonna come back from this
because it's it's so bad but trying to
make one last point then I'll shut up
it's this is a lot about the nature of
social media we don't understand how to
use social media yet the death threats
for example are because there's a low
barrier of entry for death threats used
to be if you want to make a death button
you get a call take a risk
somebody trace your color you get now
anybody you got 300 and this is what
fifty million people how many million
two hundred fifty million people on the
Internet at least one percent of them
are psychopaths and so they can make
they can make death threats few billion
people on Facebook yeah so it's like
it's it's I think we do not know how to
deal with this massive bahama Thema
thank you and and it also makes people
lesser versions of themselves because we
don't have we don't have eye contact we
can't read each other so I can demonize
you and you can demonize me and I could
say hey I made a mistake and if it's
something that supports your tribe or
whatever your bias is
then it makes you feel better but so
here's a question Jedediah everyone
hates social media but no one's getting
off it it is that we're afraid we're
gonna miss something
yeah or because we're afraid we're not
gonna be able to police the other side
or because we're things that it's good
for our own you know it's where we
belong now I think it's a little bit of
everything we're addicted to it we're
addicted to the Rochester hashtags do
not disturb we're addicted to it we're
used to being there we feel like if
we're not there and everybody else is
there we're missing something we feel
like we need it to promote the brand we
feel and a lot of people out there who
don't have a microphone we're lucky
enough to sit here and have a microphone
on television say how we feel many
people feel like well you know what I
don't work in television this is my way
to get my opinion out everyone kind of
feels like a TV star out there they get
to say their piece they get retweeted
they get it out there and for all you
know somebody with a big microphone will
pick that up and now all of a sudden
they become famous in this debate though
I have to say I appreciate the joy
Behar's of the world because they are
bluntly honest she is willing to say
what a lot of people in media won't say
which is that there is a mission to
bring down President Trump at all costs
and they are willing to do that whether
the information is true or not and that
if they see an opportunity to paint
somebody with a make America great again
hat or at a pro-life rally or whatever
the circumstance allows if they have the
opportunity to paint them as bigoted or
racist or whatever it needs to be and
tie them to Trump they're gonna do it so
I appreciate that you need people like
that because so many people in media
like Gregg said before they're sticking
to their argument but they're not
telling you why they're not being honest
about this is a mission to take down the
president they're just saying oh no
we're right these kids really are racist
and phishing they're fishing for
something in their past that might
indicate that you have to be grateful
for the people on the Left that are
telling you exactly why they're doing it
and what they're doing and and and you
know you have the facts then you know
what you're rallying against and then it
also one comes to just how we get our
news and the way that news outlets
sometimes it's pay their reporters which
is you know clicks you know you're
measured on how many times there's a
website clipped to your story does that
contribute to this I imagine it does I
think this is a bigger story about
social media I think we're all getting
played badly by this story because you
mean there's more video
more video but we only see portions of
the video I mean there's a new video out
says this - young woman said these this
is a video that says that these women
said that they were being harassed by
some of these students beforehand and we
have that pull up all right so this is
additional but not now this casts the
kids in a very negative light as having
harassed people previously with their
megawhatts in the language but I think
when I said we're being played badly
Dana I'm talking about Twitter today had
to suspend an account twenty20 fight why
did they suspend this account well
listen to this they they publish highly
polarized political content left and
right intended to divide people
supposedly based in California turns out
based in Brazil and they don't exactly
know who's putting it out but there are
tweeting a hundred thirty times a day
forty thousand followers the video which
they pushed aggressively was then bought
into by mainstream media in this country
and and again the initial interpretation
proved to be wrong but at that point
they had 2.5 million people looking at
this video and leaping to some kind of
conclusions I will say this Nathan
Phillips the veteran Native American
elder said he the kid has never
apologized to him he felt stared down
and he felt threatened by the kid and he
thought that what the black Israelites
were up to was offensive but he thought
the kids and the Israelites were about
to clash and he was trying to be a
peacemaker so now you get people on
either side especially the right in the
fact that hey these a lot of the initial
interpretations wrong saying oh now the
kids are to be protected they're angels
I think that boy we as Americans we get
fragmented divided intentionally by
these people for some reason and we play
into it we are such dummies I mean maybe
people have learned a lesson but imagine
what's gonna happen when the deep fakes
start good I think just to wass point it
is really about the chain of ownership
of that video it was mainstream media
who picked that up and didn't didn't vet
it and they should be held accountable
and they might they might be sued and
that's why Twitter now